le kemmel classe barbie sur le
territoire français pendant quelques
minutes à 20h05 à satolas me dit on il a
été expulsé la nuit dernière par les
boliviens une liste de 5000 clients
français dans les banques suisses
découverte en suisse à 1 à nice par dont
un certain nombre de personnalités qui
auront peut-être à fournir des comptes
aux douanes et à la justice enfin la
nouvelle victoire du quinze de france
face à l'ecosse 18 points pour le cop 15
pour le charbon mais monsieur bonsoir
quel symbole le criminel de guerre nazi
klaus barbie expulsés dans la nuit de
bolivie pourrait se retrouver dans
quelques heures non loin du fort
militaire de montluc à lyon à l'endroit
même où il y à 40 ans de cela il avait
fait incarcérer des milliers de
personnes est éliminé et des portes et
beaucoup d'autres et tué jean moulin et
oui l'histoire s'est brusquement
accélérée en quelques jours cet homme
que l'on disait intouchables qui avaient
réussi à fuir la justice du monde entier
en se réfugiant un jour au pérou un jour
au brésil et puis depuis assez longtemps
en bolivie cet homme va donc être livré
à ses juges et contribuer à faire
remonter en ou de pieds-noirs souvenir
klaus barbie devraient arriver en soi
corner et richard se métisse viennent de
le confirmer dans quelques minutes sans
doute à 20h05 aéroports de lyon satolas
il ya même une alerte à la bombe
tout à l'heure dans cet aéroport tous
nos envoyés spéciaux sur le territoire
ont quadrillé son trajet la plus grande
partie de ce journal sera bien
évidemment consacré à l'événement à
commencer par les circonstances de son
départ de la base
la nuit dernière alors qu'on avait
beaucoup parlé d'extradition et même un
moment de libération pure et simple
l'homme a été expulsé et remis aux
autorités françaises
en guyane patrice pollet ses portes qui
se referment sur barbie c'est pour
l'ancien criminel de guerre nazi
la fin d'une longue cavale qui aura duré
31 ans
12h55 gmt ce matin le gouvernement
bolivien décide d'expulser klaus barbie
après sa sortie de la prison centrale de
san pedro il est conduit directement
sous bonne escorte à l'ayraultport el
alto de la base
première destination lima au pérou mais
le gouvernement péruvien qui doit
transporter barbie à bord d'un avion de
ses lignes régulières aéro pérou refuse
de prendre par billet à bord
enfermé dans le salon d'honneur il
semble pendant quelques instants
à voir encore de la chance mais une
heure plus tard barbie est embarqué
discrètement bouts de fils dans un avion
hercules de l'armée bolivienne à
destination de cayenne
à cet instant le long voyage de retour
vers la france a vraiment commencé
10h55 gmt un dc-8 aux couleurs
françaises décolle de l'aéroport
militaire de cayenne
barbie est à bord donc en principe pour
lyon peut-être à evreux on a dit cela
pendant toute la fin de l'après midi
mais les derniers la formation de michel
haddad nous laisse entendre qu'il s'agit
de lyon dans quelques 1000 plants dans
ce journal
ce décès 8 vient donc d'arriver sur le
au dessus du sol français est un
territoire de klaus barbie
même lorsqu'il se dissimulait sous le
nom de klaus altmann après la guerre
faisait tout bien sûr pour éviter
l'homme ne se fait pas d'illusion sur la
justice française et sur son issue peu
avant son arrestation il ya deux
semaines choqué par la mort de son fils
et de son épouse il avait déclaré qu'il
était dans l'antichambre de la mort et
puisqu'il avait ainsi tout perdu rien ne
lui importe et plus quelle étrange
couleur que cette antichambre de la mort
dans sa bouche lui qui a conduit tant de
résistants français à commencer par jean
moulin qu'il a toujours nié avoir
exécuté dimanche dernier souvenez-vous
dans l'interview que nous avions diffusé
il avait même il avait même dit n'avoir
appris sa mort que 20 ans plus tard par
hasard dans un jour dit que sous mon
commandement
il vient deguire des des maquisards
français et non pas allemands qui ont
été tués sous mon commandement
oui on dit on dit que vous êtes vous
accusez de la mort de jean moulin
non non non non ça aussi on avait
mentionné cela il ya dix ans en a
mentionné cela mais c'est une chose qui
a déjà été jugé ou pas on vous signale
aussi comme l'auteur de la mort de sept
mille personnes et de la concentration
d'envoi en camp de concentration de plus
de 3000 personnes
non mais ce sont des choses de la guerre
ce sont des choses de la galette qui se
sont déroulés combien 38 ans alors
aujourd'hui je suis ainsi shoot souhaite
citoyens bolivien et toutes ces affaires
là aujourd'hui doivent être réglés par
la loi bolivienne
oui ça date d'il ya 38 ans pour 38 ans
lisaient cause barbie mais nous le
verrons de nombreux témoins n'ont pas
oublié
klaus barbie pourrait donc être
maintenant jugé par la cour d'assises du
rhône n'oublions pas que ces tribunaux
militaires ont été supprimés le juge qui
instruit le dossier le juge rice a été
rappelée à lyon en début d'après midi
l'heure avec vous et paul lefèvre la
procédure
est très satisfait aussi de ce
dénouement elle a même avoué avoir
acheté du champagne
madame quel sentiment avez-vous éprouvé
à l'annonce de l'arrivée de klaus barbie
en france un sentiment d'apaisement un
sentiment de bonheur
moi je viens parce que je n'ai jamais
espéré
je pensais qu'elle serait en bolivie
chez sa mort klaus barbie ni être
l'assassin de votre mari ces jeunes
assassins et il n'a jamais remis aux
autorités françaises
à quelle date avez vous vu pour la
dernière fois votre mari est bien la
dernière j'ai eu à prendre sur tant de
pression il peut citer au moment où il
faisait le chesnay les vu passer dans la
rue là il m'a pas parlé je n'ai pas
parlé non plus ici m'avait dit si kim en
compte et je ne te parle pas c'est qui
au mieux tu ne parles pas ces six
parties quelle peine que le châtiment
souhaitez-vous pour klaus barbie 5
juillet où une pendu haut et court mais
comme c'est pas possible en france
je souhaite qu'ils soient condamnés à
vie et je crois que demain quelqu'un
pour venir à ceux ci ne fait rien je
pense que ça peut arriver
ils ne méritent que ça à votre ville le
mérite que ça mais intervient pas de
repentir pas implanté et nous raconter
il y a remis aux états étaient français
idem en changent tellement éhontée que
oui des propos très fort qui expliquent
le maximum de précautions prises par les
policiers français pour assurer la
protection du criminel de guerre l
apprendre par exemple qu'un service
d'ordre très important le nez dedans
tour est le palais de justice de lyon
alors avant d'interroger béate klarsfeld
qui avec son mari a contribué à
retrouver la trace de klaus barbie en
amérique latine il nous faut écouter
deux témoignages qui éclairent au mieux
les circonstances de la mort de jean
moulin
d'abord celui de christian pineau qui
fit ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères et qui fut l'un des derniers
avant le bourg
bien sûr à avoir vu vivant gens nous
mais pour lui pas de doute c'est bien
barbie qu'il a c'est rigoureusement
impossible pour une première raison
c'est que jamais l'un des étapes on a
remis un seul de ces prisonniers aux
autorités françaises malheureusement
l'averse a été souvent prêts et
deuxièmement on ne peut pas dire qu'il
ait remis vivant ni même en bonne santé
étant donné que moi je lève humour je
pense qu'il a dû mourir dans le train
qui la menait vermesch de toutes les
hypothèses quant et temis est celle qui
me paraît la plus vraisemblable selon
vous qu'est-ce qui l'a torturé à bcia
chez barbie ya aucun doute c'est n'est
ce pas barbie avait un système à la
gestapo de lyon jean se passer de la
façon suivante quand on était arrêté on
était traduit devant barbie toujours la
première arrestation
c'est lui qui voulait interroge vous
êtes retrouvé en face de lui à bas
j'étais quand j'ai été arrêté j'étais en
face de lui pendant 11 jours de suite ce
qui prouve qu'ils avaient de la patience
quel effet vous est il cet homme-là est
bien et me faisait l'effet plutôt d'une
brute n'est pas que je prends que la
police allemand en fassions peu la
gestapo plus exactement n'était pas une
véritable police en ce sens que comme
les polices actuelle elle ne cherchait
pas à recouper les déclarations elle ne
cherchait pas à vérifier les cartes
d'identité tout ce qu'on pouvait faire
elle tapait je ne connaissais que ça
cause barbie va être jugé qu'est-ce que
vous souhaitez comme peine pour 70 la
peine mais tout à fait indifférent
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le procès je
crois qu'il est absolument important
qu'il y est en france le procès d'un
membre de l'influent est important de la
gestapo de façon à apprendre aux jeunes
générations ce que ça a été il ya trop
de gens à l'heure actuelle qui raconte
des histoires qui essaient de nier un
certain nombre de vérités évidentes
et bien ce procès aidera à prouver la
vérité et à rétablir l'histoire sur nos
bureaux de très nombreux télégrammes
émanant de tous les horizons politiques
chacun se réjouit de cette victoire sur
l'oubli et sur l'impunité pour reprendre
les propos du socialiste georges sarre
béate personnel vous avez l'habitude
avec votre mari serge
exhumé ce genre d'affaires alors est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est toujours une
bonne chose disons de réveiller les
mémoires qui flanche
c'est une bonne chose que la lutte que
j'ai commencé 11 ans avec la rive
réouverture du dossier klaus barbie à
munich
et puis j'ai démasqué en bolivie
l'identifier et privé la base d'une
honda demain je pense que c'est une
bonne chose parce que cet homme-là s'est
jamais repenti dans les interviews qu'il
avait donnée à la télévision à la radio
ou journaux il s'est félicité d'être
tous genres qui s'est nourri plaire il
n'a pas changé d'idée
je crois que c'est une bonne chose que
cet homme-là soient traduits devant la
justice aujourd'hui quarante ans après
c'est un je dirais un procès symbolique
qui montrera le travail de la gestapo en
france à travers lui sera donc montré un
procès historique surtout pour les
jeunes aujourd'hui il faut simplement
nécessaire de montrer comment c'est
possible comme la police politique a pu
tuer torturer tuer les résistants mais
aussi c'est très important parce que
barbie a sévit aussi contre les juifs
c'est lui en 44 en avril qui a donné
l'ordre de déporter des petits enfants
juifs de 3 à 16 ans du bund enfants
d'izieu et j'étais parti pour une
deuxième forme bolivie justement pour
mener campagne contre lui c'était après
la demande d'extradition de la france et
pour demander bolivienne de l'extrader
et 27 femmes madame aline prenait qui a
perdu les trois enfants et son mari et
des fusillés par barbie je crois pour
elle c'est ce sera 10 ont une solution
qui s'impose parce que justice au fait
qu'est ce que vous avez dans ce dossier
jaune qui devant du cnt klaus barbie
disons qui montre les débuts
comme j'ai commencé à m'occuper de la
fia klaus barbie ce camp 70 ans le
procureur de munich avait fermé le
dossier quand barbie en disant qu'il n'y
avait pas d évidence pour prouver qu'il
devait connaître le sort des enfants en
voyage 844 et puis un allemand au moment
où justement une faute de barbie a été
publié dans la presse allemande
un allemand vivant mali marc lecomte
actualisant je reconnais dans la photo
de barbie de 42 un homme d'affaires qui
vit entre lima et la passe sous le nom
d' iceman
et puis j'ai réuni en allemagne tous les
documents nécessaires pour identifier
heizmann barbie et bien que je suis
parti au mali m'a d'abord il a pris la
fuite est allé à la passe est un
bolivienne je les suis là bas et j'ai
convaincu je crois l'opinion publique et
le gouvernement ou de l'empêcher classe
que vous êtes allemande vous savez la
répercussion que en allemagne et en
france ce procès va avoir vous pensez
que c'est une bonne chose il ne peut pas
y avoir deux chocs en retour
certainement pas et nous avons mené avec
mon mari et des amis déportés résistants
des jeunes vis surtout ils ont mené en
allemagne le procès contre richard
harrison et je dois dire que nous avons
à part des juifs qu'ils nous ont fait
venir chaque fois avec la location des
fils et filles de france nous avons eu
aussi des jeunes allemandes en heures
dans la salle des séances
et puis je me rappelle toujours du
plaidoyer final du
du juge président du tribunal qui disait
écouter tournée des niches caja granada
pour moi c'est difficile aujourd'hui de
juger
vu que vous pourrez être mes parents mon
père me faire mon père mais il faut le
faire c'est au nouveau aux nouvelles
générations de le fait de condamner les
crimes nazis pour que des choses comme
ça ne puisse pas se reproduire
merci pour votre témoignage du côté du
gouvernement satisfaction pour l'heure
de charles hernu ministre de la défense
nous n'entendions d'antenne de midi et
puis de gaston defferre mis sur
l'intérieur qui avait bien connu jean
moulin et qui nous parlent ce soir de
son tortionnaire
il a été condamné par contumace à mort
il est donc maintenant ils puissent être
jugés
contradictoirement et que les famines de
ce et qui l'a arrêté et qui l'a torturé
puis je peux entendre leur voix
c'est un résistant eux-mêmes et qu'ils
ont connue pour dire ce qu'ils en
pensent à l'étranger les ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères a fait
savoir qu'il était bon qu'un criminel
nazi responsable de forfait contre
l'humanité et en particulier contre les
juifs soit enfin traduit devant la
justice
satisfaction également à bonn mais une
satisfaction un petit peu différente
michel meyer plutôt le soulagement oui
est officiellement il y avait une
demande d'extradition de bonnes à propos
de klaus barbie mais on l'avait déjà dit
sur cette antenne ya à peu près une
semaine
barbie pour l'allemagne actuelle c'est
un peu un cadeau empoisonné pour un
certain nombre de raisons c'est pour
cela qu'on peut parler d'un certain
soulagement effectivement klaus barbie
aurait profité des libéralités de la
justice allemand actuel une justice qui
ignore depuis 49 la peine de mort par
exemple et un jugement une condamnation
allemande un tribunal allemand eût été
éventuellement accueilli à l'étranger
comme quelque chose de bien veillant à
ce que les allemands voulaient à tout
prix éviter au niveau des autorités dans
la mesure où il ne souhaitait pas
précisément réveiller surtout de part et
d'autre du rhin un certain nombre de
ressentiment cela d'autant plus vous le
savez également aussi que une fois en
allemagne barbie en fois la constitution
allemande n'aurait absolument pas pu
être extradé une nouvelle fois par
exemple en direction de la france
quel écho michel cela éveille dans la
population allemande voulait alors là je
vais confirmé presque à 100% ce qu'a dit
béate klarsfeld tout à l'heure li en
allemagne des générations qui n'ont pas
connu cette époque là 70 % des allemands
à l'heure actuelle n'ont pas connu de
façon consciente le nazisme alors pour
ces jeunes et ça commence avec notre
génération
barbie et et autres criminels et
bourreau ce sont des sortes de
vieillards indigne un peu monstrueux que
l'on regarde avec un certain mépris
voire peut-être dans certains milieux
avec de l'indifférence pour les anciens
si je puis dire
eh bien ça rappelle bien entendu des
culpabilités désagréable éventuellement
des lâchetés des laisser faire et à cet
égard on peut parler avec barbie de la
réouverture de certaines chambres noires
de l'histoire allemande
et je ne pense pas que ce soit
spécialement agréable bien entendu il ya
des néo nazis encore il y a des des
marginaux de la marge et si je puis dire
qu'ils sont de plus en plus des gens en
repousser dans l'allemagne actuelle mais
qui ce soir ne sont certainement pas à
la fête et qui pourrait dans les
prochains temps éventuellement s'activer
ou faire un certain nombre d'actes
répréhensibles éventuellement voilà ce
que nous pouvions dire ce soir sur
l'arrivée de klaus barbie en france à
tout moment bien sûr nos envoyés
spéciaux répartis sur le territoire
peuvent intervenir dans ce journal seule
chose que nous sachions avec précision
c'est que selon l' agence centrale de
presse la cp qui cite des sources
proches de l'aéroport de paris le dc-8
militaire qui transportent klaus barbie
a atterri à 20 heures quelque part en
france sur un terrain militaire on n'en
sait pas plus françois corner par
exemple et à evreux l'un de ses terrains
militaires possibles michèle halal et à
lyon il est possible que ce soit sur un
autre terrain militaire nous le saurons
peut-être d'ici la fin de ce journal
peu de développements de l'actualité à
l'étranger si ce n'est ce mandat d'arrêt
à milan contre le turc mustafa sadac
accusé d'avoir voulu organiser un
complot contre le pape
le jugement du général jaruzelski sur la
visite du pape en pologne un événement
important at il dit et puis surtout ce
très grave attentat à beyrouth contre le
centre de recherche palestiniens
philippe jannet
l'explosion de 60 kg de dynamite
dissimulé dans le coffre d'une voiture
en plein quartier populaire de beyrouth
ouest a dévasté le centre de recherche
palestinienne et les immeubles alentour
le bilan provisoire est déjà de 20 morts
et de 70 blessés il risque fort de
s'alourdir encore ce sont
essentiellement les passants nombreux
moments d'explosions qui ont été touchés
l'attentât a été revendiqué par le front
de libération du liban des étrangers il
y a des mois que beyrouth n'avait plus
vécu de telles scènes d'horreur
les secours se sont rapidement organisés
ainsi ce soldat français qui aide les
gens à fuir les étages en feu du centre
palissy l'attentât visait certainement
la poignée le responsable de l'olp est
resté à beyrouth après le départ des
combattants palestiniens au mois d'août
dernier
absent du sens vraiment d'explosion ils
sont indemnes
cet attentat survient alors que la
situation se détériore à beyrouth depuis
plusieurs jours ainsi hier les quartiers
chrétiens de beyrouth est ont été
bombardés par les ministres de ruz
depuis le réduit des montagnes du chouf
au dessus de beyrouth
le bilan de ce bombardement le deuxième
des quartiers chrétiens en une semaine
et de cinq tués et d'une vingtaine de
blessés de source libanaise on affirme
que ses tirs d'artillerie implique
nécessairement la complicité au moins
tacite de l'armée israélienne qui
arbitres sur le terrain les combats
entre les forces chrétiennes et les
force de ruse dans le chouf c'est dans
ce film attendu que le premier
détachement des renforts français pour
la force multinationale est arrivé la
nuit dernière à beyrouth sous une pluie
battante c160 marsouins de la 9e
division d'infanterie de marine porte à
près de 2000 les effectifs du contingent
français
ces renforts ont été demandées par le
président libanais amin gemayel pour
l'aider à maîtriser une situation que la
violence et branches chaque jour
davantage un deuxième détachement
français avec des blindés légers qui
toulon cette nuit pour beyrouth
troisième étape du voyage de pierre
mauroy outre-mer après la guyane et la
martinique le premier ministre vient
d'arriver en guadeloupe à la martinique
il avait eu par deux fois l'occasion
d'aborder le fameux débat sur la rigueur
il n'y a pas de plan caché dans mes
tiroirs at-il dit pas de politique
économique avant les municipales et une
autre après et puis cette conclusion
qu'on ne vienne pas me donner
aujourd'hui des leçons de rigueur
et ce alors même qu'une majorité de
français s'attend à une politique de
rigueur économique après les élections
municipales nous révèle un sondage du
journal du dimanche
les constructeurs français de voitures
autorisées à relever immédiatement leurs
prix de 2% en moyenne
l'accord avec le gouvernement prévoit
une hausse maximum du prix des voitures
de 7,5 pour cent pour l'ensemble de
l'année une liste qui va peut-être faire
du bruit lorsqu'on connaîtra les
identités des 5000 français qui s'y
trouveraient une liste de détenteurs
deux comptes bancaires en suisse révélée
ce matin à nice la suite d'une énorme
escroquerie et de l'arrestation des
malfaiteurs
michel perron 5000 titulaires français
de comptes numérotés dans des banques de
zurich berne genève et bâle figure sur
le document informatisé qui vient d'être
saisie à nice les noms de certaines
personnalités du monde de l'industrie du
spectacle et de la télévision
apparaissant clair sur le document mais
la direction des douanes à paris tente
actuellement de décoder une autre partie
de la liste le montant des fonds
transférés dans les banques concernées
atteindrait plusieurs milliards de
francs
les policiers ont découvert le document
compromettant
au cours d'une perquisition effectuée au
domicile niçois d'une citoyenne suisse
son ami richard grazziani actuellement
détenu à genève pour escroquerie s'était
spécialisé dans les transferts illicites
de capitaux bien introduit dans les
banques suisses grazziani avait réussi à
acheter ce listing ultra confidentiel il
avait alors tenté de le monnayer auprès
de la direction des douanes françaises
contre une forte somme d'argent et a
laissé passer permanent pour franchir
librement les frontières
l'administration avait refusé un tel
marché
il
et puis le rugby avec cette nouvelle
victoire du quinze de france dans le
tournoi cinq nations aux dépens cette
fois des écossais mais jusqu'au bout les
spectateurs du parc des princes et les
téléspectateurs auront retenu leur
souffle en écoutant roger couderc dont
nous avons gardé le commentaire original
vous allez voir c'est plus vivant
les dons en rosit vue c'est le troisième
ligne centre et la valse des bêtises il
avale les jurés des fossés à ta sauce
dangereux on a là
marqué par l'absence de produire
bien visé
raisonner
ça y est c'est parti
la partie
c'est parti
et ça fait toujours des parties encore
partie allez-y les gars allez
c'est vrai
c'est jean pierre jouannet
voyez plutôt penser qu'il s'enfonce
en contact dans une rage qui ne sera pas
contrôlé
mais bonne récupération
elle appelle à la guerre de l'âge de la
joie n'est que c'est beau
rodriguez burlesque et sarenza berbizier
plus à dessein et directement glauque et
la plaque encore une fois qui débarque
et steve et ses petits chats pas à au
plaquage de nox et qui va marquer
or alléluia
à fait que c'est bon ça y est même pas
ben parce qu'on a laissé et je suis
choqué d'infos ne vont pas manquer ce
sans sommation mon petit on remonte à 12
à toutes parts a joint le passé à l'est
cet ordre andrew ranger et elle lui a
parlé
précieux
alors il attaque française là
il devient partir petit côté je pense
johann n
bien vizier d'un viseur passer les bras
ehrhoff codorniou photo nous a donné la
manière bannir ben ali jointe
on est loin
rivalta van der sar ou pas
café crème en septembre
notre essai dès 7 8 10 6
fm
le jeu
mettre dans le coup
après le renversement d'un tacle
maladroit avec berbizier
parti sur le côté opposé
le travail
on avoir redoublé c'est pas nécessaire
de bien ici
boucher
je les vendrais reconnu les portes de
ses mots
blessé il a passé trois joueurs et c'est
lui qu'on y est
voilà roger couderc ni son smoking pour
la circonstance 19 15 c'est pourquoi
j'ai mis le guen nous dire allez-y parce
qu'il ya le bac est ce soir et c'est une
tradition tous les joueurs pour les
journalistes les dirigeants mettront
king quand on est obligé d'avancer la
troisième mi temps
la troisième mi-temps alors belle
victoire mais de trouver leur histoire
dans une très très bonne équipe des
corses hd je tiens à le dire très bonne
mais battus dans les touches dans les
regroupements dans les enchaînements la
fois ce petit rien là ce petit coup de
talent de génie qui apporte toujours un
alain minute la victoire et je crois
même si je suis ridicule de dire je
crois qu'on peut faire le grand chelem
cette année en tant que la forêt pour
l'instant seuls ans
c'est vrai mais bien content merci roger
le tiercé du samedi 14 13 12
2400 francs dans l'ordre par dont 480
francs dans l'ordre dans un ordre
différent 42 francs 80 on me dit que
c'est pour 5 francs j'avais l'impression
cité pour un france on va quand même
vérifier le tiercé du dimanche
maintenant avec pierre de bresse qui va
vous proposer ses pronostics que le 19
le 14 le 17 le 18 le neuf le 11 le 15 et
le 16
et puis les propositions de la météo
avec philippe dumais
demain le temps sera très variable est
beaucoup plus frais qu'aujourd'hui et
déjà dès cette nuit il va y avoir des
formations de verglas un peu partout il
y aura aussi des coups de tonnerre mais
j'ai pas le temps de vous expliquer
pourquoi il y aura donc des averses de
pluie de neige de grêle un peu partout
surtout de la neige en montagne au
dessus de 800 m du mistral et de la
tramontane qui vont s'établir demain
dans la journée ce qui dégagera le ciel
sur la méditerranée et puis des vents
forts toujours de nord ouest qui vont
s'établir au nord dans la journée
surtout la moitié nord de la france le
baromètre est très sérieusement en
baisse comme les températures vous allez
le voir -1 degrés à grenoble 3 degrés à
lille cette adresse 10 à biarritz et
puis un peu plus chaud sur la côte
d'azur
voyez des températures qu'ils sont qui
deviennent frêche demain et bien c'est
la fête des gaston et le
soleil se lève à 8h16 pour se coucher à
17h54 bonne fête monsieur de faire je
vous rappelle que tout à l'heure selon
la société le [ __ ] de à cp c'est à
dire agence centrale de presse
la confirmation de l'arrivée en france
de klaus barbie quelque part sur le
territoire national sur un terrain
militaire mais nous ne savons pas où
voilà donc l'essentiel de l'actualité
aujourd'hui vous aurez le plaisir d'en
avoir d'en savoir plus à 23h15 avec
hervé claude et demain d'antenne 2010 à
12h45
enfin à 20 heures avec christine ockrent
bonsoir à tous
à très bientôt